anyway a whistle with this news clip
this is News Clio yeah okay
so by the time you're watching this is
gonna be way in the future so this is
old news by this point but I got to play
this I'm gonna try to sync this up it's
some [ __ ] that really uh you think you
don't really need the visual and I don't
know how we're gonna yeah here let me
just play it we'll watch it all the way
through me like pause it and [ __ ] like
that
oh yeah now we could listen to the whole
thing it's only 45 seconds long okay
yeah just play it all the way through
and then we'll then we'll Yap it up yeah
we amp it up and then I can sync it up
with the clip and then uh you know
saying [ __ ] okay it blows [ __ ] yep so
this is something that's like been going
about on Twitter and asked it
good morning TPS students it is testing
week and it's time to slay all day stay
woke beyond sleek and get that Gucci
breakfast goals
say bye Felicia to that testing stress
weather's gonna be turn right Chris yeah
a little weather gonna be the lit during
testing week a hundo pee chance of
success you've got this kids Steve about
that traffic are we looking okay better
than okay
we're talking turn Omo won't be an issue
no traffic problems around any TPS
schools to keep you from taking those
tests yeah what was that [ __ ] he did
with the bird he's trying to do the
cardi thing okay okay oh my god yeah
holy [ __ ] that was Desmond that was dope
mission accomplished by them that's
basically like our [ __ ] bachelor
character just yeah just just so much
worse yeah yeah it's lit eBay fam all in
the gang out here they have yes in the
worst part is it was like they're all
like dated references to yeah you're
like bye Felicia
yeah bye Felicia more ich flee at that
Gucci breakfast
looking designers turns turn and no FOMO
out here guys
oh my god FOMO is from like 2010 what do
you believe it's the point of that was
that was it was they have some meeting
where they're like okay we have to
appeal like we're losing our audience
member in our audience
I got it we got to appeal the teens I
feel like no teen is watching local news
on cable no I feel like as like a smart
writer just wrote it that way just so go
viral on yeah you're just going insane
like I'm gonna just feed on some stupid
ass [ __ ] for them to say I don't buy
that yeah it makes that less funny to me
if it's intentional yeah cuz it feels
like we got gamed I think we might have
no I just want to think that that's for
people that just are so so far out of
time oh cool I can't even roll my tongue
like how do they do that
the oh cool oh cool I can't do it Oh
Kurt I can't do it are you so so they do
the Oh Kurt the ocher they do that thing
oh you're being on the camera oh did I
get it there the oh oh oh oh what if you
couldn't do the sound well the role is
tongue at all what if we couldn't do it
and they're like well just let Janet
take it I want to try I want to try I
think I can do it hey I got it can't do
it now how could you do it on no I can't
fine okay fine speeding
yeah we're speeding What's Up babe am
let's get it lit with those good grades
out there okay okay let's cut you sure
no I got it I could just get you know
Janet no Danny gets everything let's do
it come on it's beating I don't know
what fine let's just be one more time
than soon all rights meeting all right
we're a hundo P with you out there
students we want to make sure you're
getting that good Gucci news so we want
to let you get an ochre breakfast get
the ocher breakfast
you just said ochre you just said over
didn't even you'd even try you just said
it with an art I'm gonna just do that
she the next time I nut Cody and I got
on Instagram live and Cody put on the
cat filter and then I did because is too
goddamn funny and then we had a to
camera set up so I was getting in with
the cat filter from the medium and he
was on the close-up
meow daddy wants some milk so creepy
like old people roleplay like 45 year
olds doing roleplay just with a little
cat at who oh my cat yeah you're a cat
yeah Cat aren't you meow meow for me
little minx oh yeah oh yeah you want
some milk
she's get she's getting too into it it's
not scratching me yeah stop stop
punching me in the [ __ ] head now what
the [ __ ] just playing with a ball yarn
[Laughter]
alright alright come on knock it off
one let's [ __ ] now shut the [ __ ] up get
that yarn out of your [ __ ] what are you
doing you know you're pushing it what
are you doing are we gonna are we gonna
[ __ ] or what do you just lapping up bowl
of milk where'd you even get that I
thought I thought the milk was like a
yeah I thought it was supposed to be
like a reference did like Mike come yeah
you ever done any like role play like
for real role play
[Music]